yeah but you know how it is when you're
old and your kids are all gone and you
got nothing to live for you walk slower
you're not as aware when you got nothing
so the unfortunately not a 73 year old
problem this is everybody
[Music]
unfortunately this isn't a happy one but
you know I figured it's healthy for us
to just to cry [__] we've talked some
[__] on somebody you know what I mean
going through a hard time go through a
hard time Nick will make it really funny
though no I won't Nick's the funny guy
for sure shut up dude I hate you so uh
check this out this 20 year old has been
arrested in the oh man this Line's way
too sad to start let's just say this
this dude who steals a forklift at
Lowe's rides it over to Home Depot and
it runs over a 73 year old oh the first
part was pretty funny
I mean take an afford to go to the Rival
store yeah that's kind of funny yeah
that's pretty funny but why Target
shopping cart and slam it to Walmart or
something
that's pretty funny but it was a
forklift would be way funnier so I see
why where he went with this yeah it was
it was going somewhere kind of hilarious
but then it went to murder
and that's not funny nick make it funny
please take it away Nick so my question
is like how did you hit a 73 year old
because she was too slow
it's pretty it's pretty slow but still
faster than a 73 year old I think the I
think the point of the story is the 73
year old was home watching TV oh my God
no just kidding
match
it's just yeah through the living room
now it's funny again because I feel I
feel like forklifts are kind of almost
easy to handle but like you could see it
coming a mile away
they're not I'm not blaming the 73 year
old I'm but they're lethal though for
sure yeah they got two [__] things
like this I'm questioning the driver
like yeah I think you're going somewhere
with the victim blaming though I think
we should stick to that you're making it
funny let's go right on the cusp of it
being funny 73 is not even that old how
to drive a forklift it's a good start
it's actually quite young keep going
like yeah I agree then the old days 73
years old but now it's like yeah but you
know how it is when you're old and your
kids are all gone and you got nothing to
live for you walk slower you're not as
aware when you got nothing to live for
yeah not a 73 year old problem this is
everybody
think about our own lives like is there
that much to live for no we don't know
it's getting dark just give up don't
even try anymore
there is a huge difference though
between a 73 year old that like kept
Athletic versus 73 year old that just
like chills on the couch because like
like in my um karate club I had guys
that were like 80 something 70 something
and I was shocked that you can actually
have a six-pack at that age without
steroids so it's gonna be Barley Street
that's the guy that we should imagine
when he's getting hit by a forklift that
he's like give it all you got man come
on [__] so my one of the guys I dormed
with he was 77 he had a freaking hearing
aid right and then we were running laps
at six in the morning he you know he
can't run like he's young but then
afterwards I was like how can you like
physically just endure all this and he
goes I worked in construction all my
life so he goes I still work
construction so I'm out in the sun and
I'm still throwing the hammer so he's
like this is not there's nothing to me
and I was like Wow and we did like a
90-minute horse stance and everything so
it's a long time you didn't have a young
man's body like fit like like a
bodybuilder or whatever but his
endurance was so good I he was beaten
like 20 year olds yeah and I was just
shocked like damn you could do that at
77 because in my mind at that age you're
in a wheelchair that's like the guy who
holds the plank record oh yeah isn't it
like hours it's hours yeah oh thank you
so you don't gotta go to work bro 60s I
think yeah yeah maybe they're just so
old that they don't even feel the pain
they can't keep track of time
it feels like I've been doing it in a
minute you want your grandparents ears
they get so big I bet you like if you
came from behind it just pinched it as
hard as you can they wouldn't even feel
it
no that guy that guy had a body finally
I got what planting is it basically it's
a Catatonia yeah he was just in a
catatonic State yeah right it deserves
no credits you're dissociating oh my God
so he got run over in Lowe's well okay
so this guy his name is Bryce Caleb
Timothy Brown who steals definitely got
five minutes how many names does he have
four but yes five is a good example when
you got four first names probably red
Nikki yeah yeah that's a good assumption
um he's accused of breaking into the low
stealing a forklift and ramming it
through the rear Gates he then made his
way to a Home Depot parking lot which
was half a mile east of the low so
imagine like you said it's not a fast
vehicle yeah if you're going like half a
mile that's like a long trip and don't
they usually yell forklift this is at 12
40 a.m by the way I don't know a.m yeah
so it's like midnight yeah midnight why
what the hell is this guy doing is he
does he have a foreign
parking lot and then there's uh
a lady glorstein Pinckney who is oh
they're even slower who was asleep in
her car so she's just a home homeless
lady well she had a car I don't know but
that's not a home that's true it's just
a recipe for the homeless lady I'm not
homeless I have a car thank you as long
as where you're running she's sleeping
in her car the forklift comes in and
just oh that makes sense yeah so it's
kind of closer to your story exactly
yeah yeah she's technically kind of in
her living room it's a little worse than
that actually oh oh great jeez why you
make it so sad because Nick's fall it's
his job to make it funny I think we got
Nick here yeah we're not even halfway
she's asleep in the car when Brown
strikes the vehicle with the stolen
forklift she gets out of the car after
the crash and starts running away and
then he follows her with the forklift
and runs it over oh so and then he flees
the scene in her car so he was looking
to do that whoa and she was runnable
it's first degree forklift yeah bro
that's that's murder that is assault
with a deadly weapon can't you just
stand behind one of those parking lot
lights and the forklift can't get to you
oh that's a good idea
yeah it's still her fault yeah what the
[__] was she thinking dude let's stand
next to us stop oh you know you know the
place where you put the shopping carts
there's two metal bars to stand in the
middle of he can't get to you he
probably thought she was still dreaming
that's true it's kind of hard to run as
soon as you wake up that's true you guys
ever try we should try that just wake up
and just [__] run
because no alarm
wake up and run we're gonna be half
asleep going I want to go back to sleep
you stupid robber yeah oh geez man it's
really hard to run in your dreams have
you guys ever had that when you had to
wake up and as soon as you wake up you
had to like do some adrenaline stuff you
must have had boot camp stuff like boot
camps like that yeah that must be fun
huh boot camp is like this they have
times where it's just randomly
um like your your normal schedule is
like four or five a.m and then you sleep
at like nine or ten and then they'll
have random like [__] around times where
it's like three a.m nice lights they
turn on the lights I don't get the [__]
out of that so just just like random
sporadic moments and you get up and all
right everyone get the [__] outside and
then you're like
it's not fun because then later you try
to go back to sleep and your heart's
like
stressed out yeah it's like oh why'd I
sign up for this [__]
Chuck Norris did our create uh um karate
boot camp really oh cool yeah he had no
like he conducted it or he he joined it
oh how old is he now no this is like I
wasn't even it was like a long time ago
in the 80s or some [__] okay like long
time ago he visited he participated and
then he was like ah it's just hard
decades ago I wasn't even there they're
using his testimonial as marketing still
yeah yeah Chuck Norris said that it was
hard as hell
just 40 years ago but it wasn't like
that we get woken up too yeah but it was
like
all right get ready and then we're like
put your keys on putting on her keys
like damn man I'm half asleep still get
into the horse dance now 90 minutes it
was still nice it was like get up guys
we gotta get we gotta get ready we're
gonna get lunch do you have a great
morning
they'll wait for you too yeah haven't
you ever had that thing happen when you
where you take a nap in the car when
you're in the driver's seat and then you
wake up and you think you're driving and
that you fell asleep oh that's dangerous
this never happened to you no that's
terrifying or also when you are driving
but you're really really tired and then
you like close your eyes for a second
when you open your eyes you're like oh
[__] you realize you're still driving
yeah oh but then then take that and add
a forklift that's her life
well hers is she's in the car right and
then [__]
ah get out of here yeah I just have to
figure out a way to get it and then he
chases you like a [__] Stone on
Temple of Doom dude like a combine
harvester just like yeah Jesus that's
scary make it funny dude I don't know
man this is tough you just gotta goal if
you're at Home Depot you gotta run
behind all the barbecues yeah there's
like a barricade right there
tough [__] she couldn't make it there
she has to go on the curb thing
uh on the forklift is so small so you
have to go over the curb they can't go
over the I wonder what the top speed on
a forklift is or on a 73 year old lady
well yeah that might be equal also if
she's sleeping in her car she's probably
not parked near the Home Depot it's fast
enough she's probably on the outside of
that that's true and also at the Home
Depot or the lows at night they bring in
all the display stuff inside the store
no barbecues out there no barbecues out
there bro no picnic benches no tough
sheds all the tough sheds all Walmart
parking lots you can you can crash for
one night yeah you could do a 24 hour
that's pretty cool I did it before you
can't do it two nights in a row what a
what a van you just gotta move your car
to a different spot two night limit huh
you got to get a paint job on your car
paint sprayer go back here
[Music]
foreign